deux trois seront ma vie
comment le porter
[La musique]
mais c'est sympa et c'était sur
long
[La musique]
juste parce que nous sommes ici ensemble
non
belle caravane
Le diplômé'
[La musique]
couture yoda
non
[La musique]
Ah
à faire
maman et papa
[La musique]
dernier jour
ne dis pas venir quel dieu où le jour où
toi
[La musique]
Oui
et
[La musique]
Bien
[Applaudissements]
Peel je viens de rejoindre la nouvelle grange
l'ambiance chaleureuse est dans l'estomac
[La musique]
champagne salut rem qu'on te chevauche souvent
notre
mais nous ceci
aux bords
showtime nous trois centres johanna maria
[La musique]
Anna
j'aurai mon
alors tu as avec moi
tu t'assois puis tu t'assois puis moi
c'était hjoed là encore ton coeur je te fais
après la chanson maintenant comment
sang métamos